we're asked to subtract simplify the
answer and write as a mixed number so we
have two mixed numbers here and like
when you're adding mixed numbers you can
do it two ways you can either turn both
of these into improper fractions and
then subtract or you can subtract the
whole number parts and then the fraction
part so let's do it that way so let's do
remind ourselves five and five eighths
is the exact same thing let me write
here in yellow as five plus five eighths
these are the exact same thing and
subtracting let me write the subtraction
sign in blue and then we're subtracting
two and one-fifth but two and one-fifth
is the exact same thing as two plus 1/5
that's what two and one-fifth really is
now if we're subtracting that means we
have to subtract the two and we're
subtracting the one-fifth distributive
property we're subtracting both of them
so we get five plus five eight and then
we distribute the negative sign minus
two minus two minus 1/5 minus one-fifth
and now we can rearrange it we can say
this is the same thing as let me do it
in orange as five minus 2/5 minus two
that's the whole number parts and then
you have plus five eighths plus 5/8
minus 1/5 minus one-fifth now five minus
two that's pretty straightforward that's
just three but what's 5/8 minus
one-fifth let's do that over here so we
have five eighths minus one-fifth now
just what just like when you're adding
fractions when you're subtracting
fractions you have to have a common
denominator eight and five are not the
same denominator so we have to find the
least common multiple of these two
numbers and if we do a prime
factorization of 8 you get 2 times 4 4
is 2 times 2 so 8 is 2 times 2 times 2
that's if you break it down into its
constituent primes 5 is just 5 because
it is a prime number
so whatever the least common multiple of
8 and 5 has to have a 5 and 3 2's in it
or another way of saying it has to be 5
times 2 times 2 times 2 which is the
same thing as 5 times 8
so the least common multiple is going to
be because these guys share no common
factors other than one really the least
common multiple is just going to be 8
times 5 so the least common multiple is
going to be 40 it's going to be 40 now
to go from 8 to 40 you have to multiply
by 5 then we have to do the same thing
to the numerator if we multiplied 8
times 5 you have to multiply 5 times 5
to get 25 so in either case we're
multiplying times 5 the numerator and
the denominator now to go from 5 to 40
we have to multiply by 8 so we also have
to do that for the numerator so 1 times
8 is 8 so now we have 25 40 it's minus
40 fortieths which would be equal to
we're going to have 40 as the
denominator 25 minus 8 is 17 17 so 5/8
minus 1/5 which is the same thing as 25
40 it's minus 8 40th is equal to 17 40
it's an 17s a prime number so it's not
going to share any common factors with
40 or at least 40 dozen isn't divisible
by 17 either so this is as simplified as
we can get so this part the fraction
part is 3 and the fraction part is 17
over 40 and we're done and this worked
we were able to separate this out and do
it pretty straightforward because in
this situation the fraction part that
we're subtracting from the other
fraction part was smaller if it was
larger it would have gotten a little bit
messy maybe would have ended up with a
negative number and we would have done
all this other stuff so that's why
sometimes it's easier to go straight to
an improper fraction for both of them
but in this case it worked out doing it
this way